[Music]
this morning we're learning about one
potential solution to the nationwide
teacher shortage tennessee has pioneered
a teacher residency program where
teaching candidates are able to work
full-time in the classroom while
pursuing their degree
meg oliver shows us how the first of its
kind program is a win for future
teachers and schools
all right here we go an hour north of
nashville tennessee at kenwood middle
school the primary wave and the
secondary wave demetrius wind tries to
explain seismic waves to this eighth
grade class all right so we know it's 8
30 because this is our 8 30 block two
years ago the 42 year old father of four
spent his days mopping floors as a
school custodian it's definitely going
to change do you feel it's a calling oh
definitely definitely it's a calling
because i said it was
it was something i wanted to do just
didn't know how it was going to happen
it all started in
facing a lack of diversity and a growing
teacher shortage clarksville montgomery
school district launched an innovative
teacher residency program recently
registered as the first of its kind in
the country sean and peartris is their
chief academic officer
if you didn't have this program in place
right now how bad would the teacher
shortage be we would have
had about 150 teachers short the program
squeezes a four-year degree into three
if they commit to teaching in the
district night school is free they
co-teach during the day with a mentor
and earn up to 27 000 a year when they
graduate their salary almost doubles how
will that change your life oh it will
open up a lot of opportunities for me i
said
i have grandkids and so that gives me an
opportunity to be there
not only financially but also
physically so here we go the program is
funded through the school district's
regular budget and with the help of
state and federal grants in 2021
tennessee committed 6.5 million dollars
over two years to support the program
now operating in 63 tennessee school
districts you have 80 teachers that are
going to graduate this year how long
will it take you to actually catch up to
fill all your positions
sometimes with the shortage it compounds
right so if it stays the same as this
year we'll be okay next year is this a
model that the rest of the country could
follow to solve the teacher shortage now
that it's registered absolutely would
you give mr wynn an a
you feel good right they're generous
so what you're looking at is your 30
seconds wynn will graduate with a
bachelor's in education in a minor in
special education in 2023 how does the
future look the future is great the
future is bright like uh the end game i
i know that once i become a full-time
teacher
that
like the opportunities are endless
endless opportunities helping fulfill
educational dreams come on adam what you
got for cbs morning's meg oliver
clarksville tennessee
what you got is the question 27 000
while you're still a student is great
yes it is i love encouraging those that
are enthusiastic about teaching yeah and
then that salary doubles when you're no
longer a student yeah i like it